die zeit wird neuberechnet muss las
vegas wegen wasserknappheit geschlossen
werden
oder gehört wasserknappheit in zukunft
der vergangenheit anders und noch mehr
themen jetzt endlich zum verwalten muss
las vegas wegen wasserknappheit
geschlossen werden
die dürre im südwesten der usa hat ein
erschreckendes ausmaß nicht so zehn
jahren hält sie nun schon an und es kann
noch länger dauern
satellitendaten zeigen nämlich jetzt
dass auch grundwasser massiv verbraucht
worden ist niemand weiß wie lange das
wasser in der region noch reicht
betroffen ist unter anderem dass vegas
das ohne dass wasser aus den dortigen
stauseen zu machen muss die
satellitendaten des grace satelliten
brachte nämlich eine böse überraschung
ans licht nicht nur das wasser in den
großen stauseen im südwesten der usa
sinkt immer weiter
eben auch das grundwasser schwindet in
erheblichem umfang zwischen dezember
2004 und november 2013 sind in colorado
flussbecken etwa 65 kubikkilometer
wasser verloren gegangen das ist eine
unglaubliche menge das ist das doppelte
volumen des größten stausee ist der usa
das lag mit stefanie castle die ins
wasser spezialistin an der university of
california irvine
sie hat ganz schlimme vorahnung das
problem ist für sie dass niemand weiß
wie viel wasser noch da ist sie sagt wir
wissen nicht genau wie viel grundwasser
noch übrig ist
deshalb kann auch niemand sagen wann es
würden manchmal verbraucht ist betroffen
von einem wassernotstand während 50
millionen menschen und 16.000
quadratkilometer landwirtschaftliche
flächen die forscher befürchten dass das
erst der anfang ist studien haben
herausgefunden dass diese region
eigentlich im schnitt viel trockener ist
als in den letzten 100 jahren jeweils
850 und 1300 nach christus gab es top
200 jahre dauernde mega tören
es ist also überhaupt nicht
unwahrscheinlich dass die gesamte region
in absehbarer zeit aufgegeben
gute nachrichten gibt es dafür für den
rest der welt gesagt
wasserknappheit ist bald vergangenheit
der wasserknappheit in der welt soll ein
ende gesetzt werden denn in deutschland
wird neuerdings mit einem heliumballon
testweise nach grundwasser forscher der
bundesanstalt für geowissenschaften und
rohstoffe testen das neue verfahren um
die wasserknappheit in trockenen
gebieten der welt zu lindern
mit hilfe von elektromagnetischen spulen
die unterhalb des ballons befestigt sind
kann wasser in bis zu 120 metern tiefe
aufgespürt werden
dabei nutzen die entwickler die
unterschiedliche leitfähigkeit von
wasser und anderen stoffen das von den
schwulen erzeugte fällt wird dann
gemessen und registriert ganz neu ist
die technologie allerdings nicht schon
vor 30 jahren wurden solche schulen per
hand ausgelegt das war aber sehr mühsam
und teuer weshalb nun die spulen wenige
meter über dem boden an einem ballon
befestigt schweben
die gewonnenen daten werden dann mit
einem computer umgerechnet und mit gps
daten wird anschließend eine wasser
landkarte erstellt
da die tests erfolgreich verlaufen sind
gehen die verantwortlichen davon aus
dass die techniken sehr bald eingesetzt
und die wasserknappheit effektiv
weltweit gelegt
feuermachen funktioniert auch in der
schwerelosigkeit treibstoff zu entzünden
funktioniert auch in der
schwerelosigkeit was dabei passiert und
wie die verbrennung aussieht haben die
astronauten um den deutschen alexander
gerst auf der iss der international
space station in einem instagram video
festgehalten
mit den neuen erkenntnissen soll die
entwicklung von antriebssystemen und
motoren verbessert werden
hintergrund des versuchs war es zu
beobachten wie sich kugelförmige tropfen
von treibstoff bei der verbrennung
verhalten
der spezielle versuchsaufbau wurde mit
kameras überwachen und wird jetzt
ausgewertet die ergebnisse sollen aber
nicht nur im weltall genutzt werden
auch für verbrennungsmotoren auf der
erde sollen sie verbesserungen in der
entwicklung für wirken medikamente
können mit licht angeschaltet werden
genauer geht es um antibiotika forschern
aus deutschland und der ukraine sind
nämlich gelungen ein antibiotikum mehr
zu stellen dass seine wirkung mit hilfe
von licht aktivieren bzw deaktivieren
lässt das ganze funktioniert weil das
antibiotikum aus teilchen besteht
nämlich bei kontakt mit licht in der
richtigen wellenlänge in ihrer struktur
verändern und diese neue struktur ist
reversibel also man kann sie rückgängig
machen und das molekül hat wieder seinen
ursprünglichen zustand unter der leitung
von professor ulrich vom karlsruher
institut für technologie ist es eben
jetzt gelungen ein solches antibiotikum
herzustellen und in zukunft sollen
solche medikamente gegen lokale
bakterielle infektionen eingesetzt
werden und nebeneffekte können minimiert
werden
da das medikament quasi das kann
abgeschaltet werden und des weiteren
könnte das auch die grundlage für eine
fortschreitende entwicklung in der
medizin gegen krebs sein das meinen die
zeit wird neu berechnet
mit dem projekt pharao wird unsere welt
zeit neu berechnet mit der neu
entwickelten ultra präzisions uhr sollen
abweichung minimiert werden
bei faro werden cäsium atomen mit einem
leser verlangsamt und ihre schwingungen
können leichter gemessen werden
mit der hilfe der neuen technik sollen
auch physikalische grundannahmen
überprüft werden wie zum beispiel die
relativitätstheorie
von albert einstein um störfaktoren zu
vermeiden findet die installation in der
schwerelosigkeit an der asf der
international space station statt doktor
festigt gibt sie der welt eine
fehlerfreie zeit offen die entwickler
bis die ultra präzisions uhr allerdings
einsatzbereit ist wird es noch ein
bisschen dauern
vorher muss sie mit referenzen auf der
erde über bestimmte mikrowellen
verbindung kommunizieren und eingestellt
werden aber dann wird unsere zeit noch
genauer laufen als bisher und noch mehr
wissenschaft wir drauf klickt da
berichte ich über einen drogenrausch
ohne drogen über besser tötende
scharfschützen und das sex wie eine
droge funktioniert täglich wissenschafts
news gibt's hier ermöglichen in der app
die links sind wie immer auch in der
video beschreibung und meine frage heute
was denkt ihr über die wassersituation
auf der erde werden wir große probleme
bekommen oder wird ihm in schalke das
ganze in den griff kriegen diskutiert es
mit in den kommentaren
ansonsten würde ich mal sagen abonnieren
favorisieren und natürlich improvisieren
bis dann bleibt krank